guys today we are so happy to have um
let me see how can I describe you I
think
you're
probably the biggest muscle of bad
friends I tell Bobby I disagree don't
fire me I think it's
[Laughter]
Carlos slugs we have the biggest
announcement of Our Lives yourselves
pinch yourselves he ain't
dreaming we are finally here today to
tell you that on September 12 the day
after you oh Annie that's not
relevant you can finally get trash
Tuesday merch and it's so cute we had
girls cool awesome designs each of these
are available at slug
fam.com each of these are available just
click the link below
we have look Kila and are modeling them
in extra larges that we're wearing as
dresses I'm wearing a small tank top and
it's my favorite tank top I've ever
owned I love it so much it's so cute I
wore it on stage last night everybody
loved it September 12 slug fam.com these
are so comfy so cute cut them crop them
and then send us Pi shirt them and go
out in the world and meet other slugs
and talk about skull you know what to
do wear us
hey sluggy Welcome to our new set we're
so excited so many fun things coming I
am on the road as always you can see me
um do live standup comedy in San
Francisco at cobs Comedy Club September
15th and 16th I'll be at the comedy
store for the next anwood and Friends
September 20th get your tickets it
always sells out I'll be in Austin Texas
at the Vulcan October 6 and 7th I'm
going to be in La Hoya shooting my
comedy special October 13th and 14th
I'll be in San Jose California at The
Improv November 17th and 18th and
Houston Texas December 15th and 16th I
am always adding dates so go to Annie
letter.com shows for
tickets hi slugs I'm so sad to miss
today's episode but you have a really
fun one ahead of you and I'm very
excited to let you know I'm going to be
doing standup over on the east coast
September 28th I'll be in DC which is
one of my favorite cities to do comedy
in and we sold out the first show
there's still tickets for the second
show we just added it and then September
30th I'm going to be doing a very
special show in Boston at the Wilbur
Theater and I will have a special guest
with me I'm just really excited I can't
wait to see you guys at these shows you
can get tickets at Esther on ice.com for
a limited time nutriful is offering our
listeners $10 off your first month
subscription and free shipping when you
go to nutri.com and enter the promo code
trash find out why 4,000 Healthcare
professionals recommend nutriful for
healthier hair nutri.com spelled n t r
fol.com promo codr that's nutri.com
promocode TR order your THC products
from mood today for 20% off your first
order and free gummies go to hood.com
and use promo code trash Tuesday that's
hello m o
o.com promo code trash Tuesday for 20%
off your order and free gummies
you guys we have Jesse Jet Ski juicy
Johnson on today thanks I have something
to add to that Jesse Jet Ski juicy ski
mask little veins was there another one
tiny veins tiny veins apparently we did
an IV thing in Kansas City and with Wes
from The Challenge in his Mansion what's
up Wes literally in a mansion and these
he had these nurses there and they
hooked us up to the IV and they had to
keep putting mine in because the my
veins were too small yeah wait they can
use a little thing you a little
butterfly one no no no yeah butterfly is
easy but I'm saying like there's a vein
finder a vein finder like a stud yeah no
that's exactly what it is it's this like
little light that you put over and you
can find your veins like a lot easier I
consider myself a stud finder my mouth
just goes a gape when I find a
stud wait juicy why do you go by jet ski
both all both of my nicknames mostly all
of them they just sound like my name
Jesse so I I just I went to this Open
Mic years ago in this in Arizona and
they gave everybody like 10 minutes and
it was this guy's first time ever on
stage and he told this long story about
writing a jet ski and he said the word
jet ski literally hundreds of times and
my friend leaned over and Jason Hill and
he was like you should go buy jet ski
and that's just as simple this guy is
about to ride
you but so no Act 10 minutes straight
yeah but then I like went on Facebook
and changed my name to jet ski and I was
saying Kawasaki he was sponsoring me and
it was clearly a joke and wait but they
still no one's reached no jet ski
company has reached out like SEO or
anything like no nobody's reached out
I what the hell honestly this is the way
to capitalize if I was the CEO of seidu
or any of these other jet ski companies
or Kawasaki I would have already hit you
up by now it would be awesome I'd love
to sell jet skis at my shows just have
them on the merch would be amazing yeah
and then if you ever come outside we're
doing merch out on the dock yeah you
know on the dock you know what bad
friend should do instead of having just
a regular seat they should have you on
an actual jet they should and they
should have one of the freaking jet ski
companies sponsor that or just give you
one Bobby could afford a jet ski he no
he
can't you guys don't know Bobby's broke
I didn't know that oh no I'm going to
get Bobby's broke you guys didn't know
go Reddit
go go Reddit go that's a great podcast
name that's my nickname Reddit Letterman
Reddit Letterman have you guys um ever
tasted breast milk from either a friend
or a family member my
mom me too's Mom same answer what I
wasn't a
kid um are you guys into that is there
because you know like Esther has his
like huge huge desire to take it from
the tap as an adult I did not know that
you but now it reads true if you think
about it you go yeah I'm not
interested I um will try anything if you
ask for you I mean there are people who
like like there was this one documentary
I had watched where this guy like he
searches and pays a lot of money for
like a weeks weeks and weeks supply of
breast milk that's all he does but he
wants it out outside of the breast he
doesn't want to suckle it out of the
boob well he I think It reversed he he
believes It reversed his cancer or
something like that something terminal
so I feel like Todd would want a suckle
breast milk from me kind of hot like he
wouldn't admit it but he would be really
into it I think I feel like I I don't I
drink oat milk so if I'm not even
drinking cow's milk while am I drinking
human milk but oat milk is so thick I'm
well I mix it in I'm not just like
drinking it from the cart oh my God
she's chugging it is is oat milk still
in I thought oat milk was out I just
drink it because it seems like the most
sustainable milk oh she's so healthy and
helpful you know it's not sustainable
what jet skis I know very bad for the
make up for it in the milk Department
very bad for the environment I like the
idea of you chugging o milk standing up
on a jet ski all right let's make it
happen let's do it have you ever like
breastfed sorry I'm still no my friend
squired her breast milk and I was
shocked at the way it came like a super
soer it yeah no it comes out like like a
shower head it comes from all Corners
whoa and it was I was disgusted I was
like I didn't know I would have that
reac was like it was like on me I was
like get this sticky mess off me um my
mom told me that she's like
breastfeeding a baby is like you feel
so she's like it just feels so good like
it kind of hurts like the baby will like
bite you and stuff but she's like but
you just feel so like where you're
supposed to be in life but then I also
wouldn't breastfeed so I was like it was
kind of a dig at me you wouldn't do it I
wouldn't stuggle that no have you seen
my mom's boobs no I have not pass
no I'm just kidding imagine if your baby
would just rejects your no I did and my
mom was like you're
like I was like but I was traum I was
like born traumatically oh that's right
you came out ass first right I came out
ass first they had to pop me out you
twerking out of there I told you I think
I got tokened by the doctor toen like he
went in he went his hands into went into
my mom's vadge and mine yeah like a
kebab
he he fish hooked me out so
funny
oh wow lawsuit and then you were like
I'm not breastfeeding I was like but my
brother would
breastfeed was like Mom what do you want
me to do try now pull them out let's go
[__] would she have you both on at the
same time no because I wouldn't I had to
be bottle fed I didn't want nothing to
do at all like You' never I was like I
didn't I only liked my brother I was
born I would like cuddle in with my
brother but I didn't like to be held or
anything cuz that's pretty epic to have
twins and just have one on each just
hanging hands free yeah that's kind of
cool hands grocery shopping getting
things done her boobs are kind of like a
roller coaster because one goes up and
one goes down oh how fun sorry
mom um what do you guys I don't know if
you've seen this viral Tik Tok but
there's this girl who basically is like
super upset because she wasn't afforded
the how do you say like I think she
tried I know she was going to say this
is at me go
ahead go
ahead no this is definitely that at you
cuz I don't even think you would agree
with her no she's but basically there's
this girl who's like hey like I should
be
um there concessions should be made to
accommodate my time blindness she has
time blindness basically I think she has
ADD right an she just late for
everything yeah yeah she's always late
for everything and she calls it time
blindness and she was like this job that
I you know applied for should consider
that this is like a disability it's so
funny to go in and they're like what do
you want us to know about you she's like
I'm going to be a terrible
employee and I'm going to go crazy if
you don't so annoying that's my biggest
pet peeve when people are like like so
late all the time and they just don't
respect anybody else's time to hear that
there is now can we have JY off the show
I'm a little bit easier about time cuz I
grew up with Island time so like time is
just a suggestion you got time she got
time blindness you have Island time yeah
it's I got baby but I I I feel as though
like
um I think it's just like cultural
differences too but but but if I know
someone is like really a big stickler
about time then I'm like on my [__] but
because I'm scared but um I try but it's
like it's just I like I can't believe it
like I'll be like I'll get up so early
like ready to go and then I'm like oh my
God I like look at the time I'm like are
you [__] kidding me me too I would
need like an alarm going off like every
5 minutes going like you have to do this
now you have to do this now and I think
I had to just I try to just accommodate
other people in the sense where it's
like if I'm late just start like with
the show I'm like just start without me
because Esther's very like she has like
anxiety around time starting like not
that I'm saying she's wrong or anything
but most people are like start on time
yeah but I don't ever want to
inconvenience anyone with my lateness so
I'm like whatever we can do to just
start so everyone can leave at the same
time oh yeah I've loosened up a little
bit where I'm not like so anxious about
getting somewhere late but it's just
been drilled in to me as as a kid of
like you got it if you're what is the
saying if you're on time you're late
yeah oh no and it's still like I know
it's like in a thing that I carry like
it's not like the way everyone should be
but I am like programmed like that yeah
but it's more normal for that cuz people
things need to get done true yeah I just
hate when people are like let's meet at
5:00 and then it's like 5:30 and they're
like I'm on my way and then they get
there at 600 and they're lying they're
lying about being on their way you know
on their way means they're like wiping
their ass and brushing their teth head
move I'm on my way I swear to God I'm on
my way like 3 hours later I'm on my way
that's the worst to lie to people about
where you are and oh yeah just be honest
I'm late I'm like all right I'll go do
something else my friend Abby lives like
there's no service like when you you
enter she lives like in the hills in
Burbank and so you enter the Hill area
and there's like one spot where you can
text and talk on your phone and then
you're going to have
no so there would be times where I'm
like almost there and then I would just
stop and like oh I'm to like check my
phone real quick and make sure I get
everything done and I would literally be
like oh my God Abby I am like at your
house I've been here for an hour I'm so
sorry like I would just completely like
get absorbed in my phone no I I feel at
the bottom of her Hill like it's so
[__] up i' be so pissed no she should
be pissed but she wasn't and that's why
we're still friends so I have really
good the grace of her of Abby and God I
have really good long-term memory like I
can remember things from ages ago like
the the S like the most like the
smallest details I can remember but I
have really bad shorts memory like 5
minutes before a meeting I could be like
okay I got five minutes before I will
blow it off and completely forget within
that five minute time frame that I had a
meeting like that's how not present I am
like in the moment I'm the exact
opposite are you counting down those
five minutes in your head yeah and I I
my long term is bad but my short term is
good I feel like that's more that's more
important to have better shortterm
because you're actually getting things
things done in the moment I'll just
complet completely forget in that five
minutes I always have that feeling where
I'm like I'm supposed to be doing
something oh that's anxiety I think I
just started no no it's not putting my
[__] schedule in my phone I've been
I've gotten so good but it's only been
this year that I started really using my
calendar it's crazy like Stella was
asking our dates and I was like I have
do you know I have to ask two Shaman I
have to ask my manager my agent like I
there's so many people I have to hit up
about what is happening in my life for
the next six months you got that Google
Calendar got that Google Calendar but
for some reason my Shaman doesn't want a
trace so he's not on I'm just kidding
Shaman's not on
Gmail how does that work like is it is
is a shaman more sought after if they
play the game of teas like you can't
have access to me only during ceremony
and like do they that that is that a
lore that they're hard to reach
sometimes why Shaman and I love each
other if I didn't talk to him in between
I mean it would still be fun to see him
and stuff but it's like we love each
other I do sessions with I would love to
see a shaman with a blue toaste and like
a
Blackberry go for
Jose or whatever go for what would do
Shaman's name be I can't say mine um um
juy do you talk about your relationship
at all like on podcasts not really I've
started doing like talk doing jokes
about it now and on tour you know we do
like a room with thousands of people and
I'd be like I don't talk about it on the
podcast but I'll tell you guys since
it's just us like 3,000 people but but
yeah I've been slowly talking about it
now and uh yeah can we talk about that
you're you're single yeah I've been
single for quite a while now so it's
fine to talk about I'm not really
looking to date though but that's a
really good move yeah yeah really good
move I think that's like been the most
valuable thing I can't say valuable you
already know that I love it um but it's
like being alone is so kind of
intoxicating oh my God it's so much time
and fun and you don't have to worry
about nothing yeah I mean you guys were
together for a long time like what was
it like like did it feel like Grim well
Annie knows like we he so he he's a
great guy great heart and everything it
just kind of moved like platonic so I
can relate to that yeah so it was like
we were just kind of became roommates
but we still love each other um but we
are also in a really bad situation uh
living situation CU we any know this it
I mean I call it like it was like a trap
house there was like a lot of drugs
going in lived in a crack a cracked Den
yeah several people it was like infested
it was just like five other dudes living
there and then other people would come
in and out to crash on the couch or in
the shed yeah there's just no privacy or
anything there yeah I felt like I felt
like I I don't want to say I felt like a
prisoner CU I think that's extremely
disrespectful toison two prisoners right
two Australians two Australians and I
know there's one in the building but I I
didn't like living there so I had I had
to get out yeah but he was kind of you
know we were struggling comics and we
both like helped each other and it was
cheap to live there and we kind of were
on food stamps at the same time at one
point and I remember like one time using
my food stamps to get us a sandwich but
I didn't have enough and so he like
covered the other dollar and split the
swi like a parking lot and like we have
like all those struggling moments
together that will kind of bond us
forever but uh but yeah now I it's hard
to adjust to my new reality well you
have a bad long-term memory so you'll
forget about him soon yeah a couple
years like it's scary cuz you're right
sandwich but now yeah now I'm like I
wake up and I'm in this beautiful
apartment and it's like clean and um I
feel I'm like adjusting to feeling
successful CU for so long I've not been
and it's hard for it was hard for a
while to even say that yeah you know you
don't want to be like oh you have an ego
or whatever but like for me and how far
I've come like I feel very successful
now yeah yeah and it feels great and you
should yeah yeah but that's a great
feeling though to have your own space
finally and to kind of and it like
aligned well like you found the right
place it wasn't hard to get it was like
everything worked out oh yeah well I've
been looking for like a like over a year
like on Zillow was like my porn I would
every night fall asleep just scrolling
through like houses and dreaming and
finally I just had to do it and I saved
up all this money from working at The
Comedy Store and I like it literally
took everything I had saved to get the
deposit and it was just like a gambling
move and as soon as I got in we did the
bad Friends tour and that financially
set me up to like keep living there and
now I'm headlining and finding other
ways to be independent financially [__]
yeah congrats oh yeah thank you yeah I
owe a lot I owe a lot to them and like
uh it really feels sometimes like it
saved my life my situation yeah yeah
yeah I I remember when Bobby um first
talked about you well before you even
did bad friends but he always had like
an affinity for you he always remind him
about it he's lost
it well he's broke now you're the rich
one yeah is that what we're trying to go
with he's broke we bonded over the tour
and I think it like he's kind of just
trying to keep me in an employee space
instead of like a friend space um I know
actually I think I think you're wrong if
he's trying to do that or if he feel
like he's giving you like negative
attention it's probably you've entered
the family space Oh that's great well he
calls me his daughter all the time yeah
and also a lot of times he accidentally
calls me Jews yeah you know like do you
realize how much he terrorizes Jewels oh
yeah you're right there is not like a
real I've never had I've never seen them
have a sweet moment it's like pure
Terror oh that's my future yeah so
that's I think you're just family space
now well they they paid me really good
on the tour and I spent way too much
money money but I wanted to thank them
and so at the end of the tour we were at
this hotel and Bobby was sitting on the
luggage cart and this guy is like he was
so scared excuse me can I can I get that
cart and Bobby stands up really fast and
his fanny pack is wide open and all his
stuff falls out and this bottle of
cologne shatters and he's in the Gass
and he's like that was a $300 bottle of
cologne and then we went to New York and
I saw that cologne I like I kind of
played it down I was like oh my God what
what was it and he told me and then I
looked it up and they had that store
right by our hotel in New York City
which one was it I I'd have to look it
up is it lbo yeah yeah and it was like
he's a $300 and so it was like way too
much money to spend but I was like they
took me on this 33 shows you know
whatever so I went and I got him the
bottle of the cologne and he was really
upset about
it he probably is well he's never going
to watch this so I think it's all right
but he probably kill me for saying that
that story cuz I've never it but he was
like never ever do that you know he I
think it came from a place of like he
didn't want me spending my money on him
exactly but I was like so excited so
sweet that's such a good present I love
a present where you like you scheme a
little behind the scenes yeah all day I
was like excited to give that's so sweet
I love how you're like that you always
send me like the sweetest text messages
and stuff they always come to be like so
randomly it's like yeah oh yeah people
should always be sweet yeah I learned my
lesson I'll take presents but I love him
to death you know and so it's like I
just it's just funny to be like okay
just don't show it yeah like maybe
reserve it only for his birthday cuz he
gets real bratty on his birthday like if
you don't get him a great gift you will
get called no your present's
perfect that's so good that's a good
Instinct don't waste it on him anymore
yeah don't waste it on him but on his
birthday if you show up empty-handed he
will remember that and he will hold you
to he's so confusing he's but on his
birthday he just turns into like
everyone should give me everything I
went to his birthday party at that
restaurant oh that's right that was fun
yeah his 50th that was cool that was
really fun I think Esther was so high
she like broke her vegan diet and ate
beef all night she was just so high she
was like what is said I was like beef
you can't have this she's like yeah I
can oh my God thank God she broke that
vegan diet I was like well you're a
Korean barbecue spot so this is the
perfect you're have a lot of pickled
things if you
don't be eating pickled stuff your show
was so fun by the way that's when I last
texted you she did that yeah two shows
at The Comedy Store sold both sold out
so fun Annie pays really well but it was
really great and then all those people
from that reality show were in The Green
Room and yes oh the yeah jety has come
with me on so many like challenge hangs
and has never watched The Challenge I've
never seen it well too it's like insane
there's so it's like been on for 20
years or more yeah have do you watch it
yeah I used to in the early years so all
of Annie's I not the newer cast like the
newer guys I don't know but like the old
school well they bring them back I know
W I know um you know CT I know all those
guys CT we got to get CT we need CT and
Johnny Bananas we're coming for you Tori
come on Tori we're meant to be wa who's
Tori Tori is like she okay so she used
to be engaged to Jordan who was at the
the Annie and friend show Jordan did my
podcast Jordan was born with one hand he
is he wins everything he won a
tug-of-war contest with a man with two
hands yeah that he's smart so like he
was watching he watched for like the
tell of when the guy was going to pull
and then he would give slack so he would
fall off the back like he's just smarter
and better than literally everyone and
he beats every two-handed person he even
like one one challenge they he went
skydiving they made them Skydive and his
parachute didn't work and he broke like
he basically broke his knee in the
beginning of the challenge and he still
won he just is so unbelievable so we had
him on um Annie wood and
he um we like he wouldn't leave like
Todd and I were like we cannot believe
how long this person is here he was like
when are we going out to eat so we just
like have a Jordan now like Jordan comes
to all of our stuff and him and Todd are
so loud they get wasted and they're
screaming The Green Room was so loud it
was like you were like you like guys
they can hear you you're so good at like
you're like we're late it's loud I'm
always like I know I'm so such a nerd
but they also there a bunch of drinks
were spilled so the ground was really
sticky it was sticky it was crazy
Jordan's always wearing a cowboy hat and
like oh yeah overalls that are down like
but he's so cute he's so awesome it was
wild but yeah those shows were really
fun I wanted to set him up with Whitney
before she got is he what does he look
like I want to know I'm still single
Jordan wisley am I chopped liver are we
not throwing options my way anymore you
reject my whities but he's a Venezuelan
or something too or pan panan wait he's
white he's half pan P panan Manan oh no
no no he's cute he's so hot he's the
best's yeah no he's not he's number one
he's so
cool oh yeah he's super cute he's so fun
he's so funny he's the best he's doing
race car driving now oh he a fiance yeah
no he was engaged to um Tori but they
broke up oh I see and Tori I'm like Tori
come to me [__] come to me she's like
Philly
area he is super cute yeah know he's
number one but it's like he's always
down he's have I really rejected your
whes yeah it's okay they're Island whes
too I'm like they grew up on
Islands ever actually like met any
though that's a thing like I I I can't
be attracted to a guy just on paper
alone of course hard can't you're dating
apps yeah it's hard so dis well I always
think you're like you have to go through
a funeral like you meet the person and
you're on a date with them and and
you're like you have to have a funeral
for the person you created them to be
yeah that sounds exactly right but even
then like I can't even create an idea of
them when I see them I just think that
they're they all they're all the same
they all open with the same line they
all what's the line that you get um
something about my weekend or something
if they try to be too funny or too
clever then it's like uh red flag how
many times have you texted that same
sentence to someone today and I know
it's just a numbers game I'm not hating
on people on dating apps but like
personally for me it's just a snoozefest
every guy in La has like their surfing
pick their Burning Man pick like it's
very specific um and they all kind of
just start to feel the same look the
same the only guy I went on a date well
two guys I went on a date with amriah
and um the one guy like paid extra to
like Direct Hit me that I liked I was
like okay even though he probably doing
it for like a lot of people and we had
good VI he was from Philly and he was
brought up Quaker and we had all these
like really good vibes like talking like
we like had good text and then we hung
out it was kind of fine but then he just
wanted to keep texting and would never
hang out I was like I don't have time
for this yeah you're like his new better
help therapist yeah I'm like am I your
therapist what's going on but um we
should go to the singles bar but then
wait Jesse we should go every talk to
would just be waiting to talk to you was
kind of leaning in on you like I like
this girl no because we are so opposite
you're blonde I'm Brown I think that you
and I together looking for boys in the
wild we'd be unstoppable CL yeah we'd be
unstoppable I'd be on the god mic I'd be
on the god mic at the bar the bar you
guys we've got them lined up in the
corner we're going to be in Austin
together that would be really fun when
are you guys going to be in Austin
together so next weekend yeah I'm
headlining sunet strip um in Austin on
the 25th and then tiger brother lives on
the 26th so I'm going to wait let's go
out that would be really fun you're
going to be able you got to bring your
cowboy I'll bring my t toas I think Tas
is an Austin brand I'm also really aw
you want meet us there I'm jealous I
can't no just what weekend this next
weekend next weekend family vacation
cocaine come on bring your whole family
we need as many wingmen as we can get
cowboy cocaine no that's been my dream
for Annie to Just Wing me or Wing us
yeah cuz she I'm just giving you cocaine
for some reason some reason I'm like I'm
always giving Kila Coke in every story
it's just me like no one else is doing
it I'm just like go Kila go imagine how
look at my instrument you know this
thing is going to snort some [__] up
well how do you okay how do you have
game at a bar though because my whole
thing is like I'm not going to hook up
the night me neither and so like how do
you I feel like at a bar when you go out
guys are just they're that's all they're
trying to do yeah so then I'm just
talking to them to be like make friends
first yeah same yeah it takes me a while
I don't sleep with i i because it takes
me a while to be attracted to somebody
it's very rare that I'm attracted to
someone like right out the gate and
usually if I am that will Wayne over
time like if I'm super attracted to them
initially I know like the next week I'm
like it I like slowburn burs when I'm
like oh I think I'm attracted and then
it starts to grow um so I'm with you on
that we're we're definitely not [__]
next weekend hell yeah we're not making
out in the bathroom I'll make out I'll
make out out in the bathroom I had a
thing when I used to drink where in
Santa Fe where I'd be like we have to
make out like I I liked making out like
behind the dumpster and stuff I don't
know why I was like this so funny like
theall fun I was always like let's go
make out and parties in college it was
always like going they was guys were
always putting me up on the the sink oh
yeah see making out is super fun you
can't bang though but no banging no
bathroom bangs none of that I feel like
an Austin never a bathroom bang bathroom
Banks later on later on yeah sure but
not my first night in Austin though when
I lived in Santa there's something about
a country town too makes you want to
just get it in a bathroom well abortions
are illegal in Texas so so no bangs
hotter yeah yeah there's more risk well
you bring the baby across state lines
and then you get rid of it yeah but I I
travel with my my Julie pack my
emergency contraceptive so we're good
what is it it sounds like a vape but
it's what if it came in Vape form oh my
God that's actually Julie I know Julie
if you're watching Vape
emergency contraceptive that's awesome
dude people would be down you could
partner with
juel be it would be J uu l i e yeah
collab wow that's pretty genius um no
but it's an emergency it's like it's
emergency contraceptive so even if he
you know blows a load you are covered
got that plan B yeah yeah yeah in a VAP
Vapor plan a plan
Austin got a lock F you up but I think
they they party out there it's like
downtown Austin which is where the club
I'm at and the theater you're at it's
like all in that downtown area and
everything's really close walking
distance all the bars and stuff so it's
like a big party town this probably
won't be released until after but um I
should start to recruit some hotties
right line them up for us you find I
wish you were there I know what the [__]
I know and I'm going to an Esther Hicks
seminar in Philly with my parents what's
an Esther hick seminar eser gets real
country it's yeah it's a hick Esther
it's Esther in cowboy
boots and she's got dip she spits on you
I'm like oh my God Stella would be into
it um Esther Hicks is like she channels
she supposedly like
channels
beings something past a medium Med she's
no it's like will you look up a
description of Esther Hicks
is this something your parents planned
or you dragging no I'm bring I'm
bringing them that's so cool it's going
to be
fun Esther Hicks okay yeah I don't know
how to explain her people call her the
dark arts okay is an okay is an American
inspirational speaker Channeler a
Channeler and author she has co-written
nine books with her late husband Jerry
Hicks um but it is let's see hold on go
down a bit she
rolls um I want to know specifically
what channeling
is it's awesome I listen to her stuff
all the time you're like channeling a
person hold on I'll find it is it more
paranormal specific people no no no it's
like it's like oh there it is okay a
Channeler so channeling so a conduit in
ESO esoterism esoterism I can't [__]
read a conduit I can't spiritual
discourse is a specific object person
location or process in a seance or
entering using psychedelic medicine hers
is like your ultimate being wants you to
be happy and you're here to be happy
it's like about manifesting so
communicating with the spiritual realm
or the metaphysical energy and like
every time you're upset it's because
you're not you're not congruent with
your spirit like your spirit just wants
you happy loving everyone and if you're
not it's cuz you're I felt like that the
other like my body and spirit were
separate I went to go make a like a
protein smoothie and I was like we're
going to treat ourselves to something
nice L what I thought I was like why am
I saying weird but I was talking to
myself as we were two people I lost it
and take my vitamins did you guys both
like this protein smoothie we both liked
it and then I chopped it up to that I'm
a Gemini so I like yeah there's a couple
things going on I always get along with
Geminis every boyfriend here everyone's
always like I'm an Aries and I'll I'll
cut you off completely if you say one
bad thing to me but I'm also full of
love but Geminis are psychotic and
you're like wait what's the what's the
general like idea like what's what are
Geminis supposed to be like two faced
that's everybody says two faced but I
think there is like the sign is the
Twins and there's a duality and I've
found with myself like I think it works
well being a comedian because I play
Devil's Advocate on everything like it's
really hard for me to really pick a
stance on something because I see like
all the sides to it that's how Todd is
too and Todd Gemini and I'm like he's
not he's not twoo faced he just sees
every it's like he's more empathetic and
kind CU he can see everyone where
everyone's where everyone's coming from
yeah and it's probably really annoying
too if you're talking to me about
something cuz I'll be like well a lot of
that well it could be this or I do
appreciate that though it's good for
conversation yeah cuz sometimes like I
know that I there are times where I
really need someone to just agree and
back me up especially if someone's like
done something you know or like a boy
say for instance and I'm like he did
this or he did that I do and Annie's
really good with this where she like is
very like well [__] him and [__] this
and like it really you know I feel like
super supported in that moment but there
are times where I'm a little bit
unreasonable and I do need that voice to
be when I'm healthy I'm going come on
when I'm unhealthy I'm like [__] this
guy let's kill him that might be where
the two- faced thing comes into because
like if my friend is telling me
something about like her relationship
I'll always have her side like my best
friend but my head I'm also thinking of
the things of like well you could do
this this and this to get out of it but
I'm not going to say that cuz sometimes
you don't need to hear that sometimes
you're just venting so maybe that's
where that comes from that's so hard
when people are just venting I'm always
like I can give you Solutions out of
this I know it's venting sounds like it
should like be refreshing and cool you
off but it's us really like yeah
speaking of venting
[Music]
whoa did you guys know that hair
thinning will happen to approximately
one out of two women sitting on this
couch oh my god did you know that one of
the women on the couch has such thin
hair that she Clips in hair extensions
and then it also makes it thinner I I
had no idea did you know America did you
know that and did you have you ever
wished that you had visibly thicker hair
how about less shedding are you tired of
dealing with thinning hair nutriful is
here to help their hair growth
supplements use drug-free ingredients to
Target root causes of thinning hair and
promote healthy hair growth for real and
what I love about nutriful is that they
don't promise an overnight fix which is
why I know they're legit you take four
pills a day I've been taking it for I
think close to two years now and I'm
telling you my baby hairs are now adult
hairs they are in college did you cry
when you had to drop your baby hairs off
at school I really did I'm like you guys
are growing up so fast every girly that
asks me like Esther how is your hair so
thick I literally always say if you want
thicker hair the only thing I trust is
neutri fall because like you said it's
not an overnight fix this is the real
deal and they're using real ingredients
that will actually treat the issues and
nutrifil is the number one dermatologist
recommended hair growth supplement
clinically shown to improve visible
thickness and strength and in a clinical
study 86% of women reported improved
hair growth after taking nutriful
women's hair growth supplement for six
months take the first step to visibly
thicker healthier hair for unlimited
time neutrals offering our listeners $10
off your first month subscription and
free shipping when you go to nutri.com
and enter the promo code trash find out
why over 4,000 Healthcare professionals
recommend nutriful for healthier hair
nutri.com spelled n u rol l.com promo
code trash that's nutri.com promo code
trash okay so whether you're new to
cannabis or you're an old Pro there's no
denying that many of the products on the
market seem iffy at best and when you
want to relax iffy is sort of the last
way you want to feel and you don't
really want to conjure that up right and
mood puts an end to the guessing games
it's 100% federally legal Delta 8 and
Delta 9 THC you can have Shi straight to
you no doctors no waiting just
Affordable Legal THC and for a limited
time mood is giving our listeners free
Delta 9 gummies and 20% off your first
order visit hood.com and use promo code
trash Tuesday my favorite thing about
mood which is kind of the whole reason
that I like cannabis is that you can
tailor what you ingest like to your your
exact mood that you want so they have
energized creative focused euphoric
erotic sleepy chill social I've been
using body Soother a lot lately like I
just love to like pick what I exactly
how I want to feel pop it in and have
that exactly happen like that is such a
relief to me and like Esther said it's
great for both beginner and Veteran
users however you like to take THC mood
has you covered ready for a good time
without the guest work order your THC
products from mood today and for 20% off
your first order and free gummies go to
hood.com and use promo code trash
Tuesday that's hello o o.com promo code
trash Tuesday Tuesday trash Tuesday for
20% off your order and free
gummies so you guys are going to the
Esther Hicks thing and like what is it
just a seminar like is it a couple days
people do like hot seats it's just one
day people will come up and they'll be
like I'm you can look at one on YouTube
real quick it's
like do you get brought up on stage if
you want if you manifest it I feel like
my dad's going to do a hot seat I'm
exited I want to be channeled it's cool
it's really cool
stuff like people will go up with like
questions and oh I like this and she'll
be
like I don't know she just like guides
people back into it's all about like
putting things in your Vortex and what I
like about her messages it's like the
like the joy in life is the process of
getting somewhere so rather than looking
at your life like oh I'll be happy when
I have this thing you're like satisfied
with your your time towards it you know
like oh I'm so excited yeah I I had this
thought a couple weeks ago when I was
with my family in Hawaii for my sister's
40th birthday and it was like just a
random it wasn't even a thought it was
more like a feeling and like I looked at
her I looked at my family and I was like
wait I already made it not because I
started to make money I made it a long
time ago the fact that there are so many
things like stacked against me when I
was young and somehow I'm still living
and breathing and there's air in my
lungs I'm like [__] I made it and it was
such this this feeling that washed over
me where I was like everything could end
today and it will be okay yeah I wish
everybody was in that place that's
really beautiful the feeling came and
went it did yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
back into the fog is another person I
listen to she does like affirmations and
her whole thing is she's like the most
important thing in life is breath and
the fact that we all can breathe is and
she's dead now so it's like uh
oh doesn't last forever but it's like
um it's just yeah I don't know it's nice
to just remember that you have so much
to be grateful for and if you can
acknowledge and let yourself be loved
you realize how loved you are you know
yeah I think people forget the original
Dream remember when you were just like I
just want to make rent or I just want to
room to myself or I just want to not
worry about um groceries next week I
don't want to have to steal this block
of Chase from Albertson you know like I
don't want to have to eat shrimp
crackers for three straight weeks can we
get off the to shrimp crackers sounds
great cers you know like Top Ramen
cannot be you know two out of three
meals a day like the original Dream we
just so quickly forget it I think but if
we were to write that down like imagine
if we wrote it down then and all the
things we needed and wanted and read it
now I did that I listen I used to listen
to I've always listened to self-help
things but I listened to this guy Brian
Tracy when I first quit drinking and
started doing comedy in New York and I
wrote down he had he had this book
called goals and I wrote down you write
goals in positive present tense you do
10 goals and then you do three things
you can do to get those goals so it
would be like if I wrote things like and
I was so embarrassed cuz I barely
started I hadn't even done an open mic
yet and I was like I want to be on
Chelsea Lately so I was like I am like a
panelist on Chelsea Lately I am you know
all these things and I was like if
someone found this I'd be so embarrassed
and I got that within a year I was on
Chelsea Lately in a year you go I am on
Chelsea Lately or like goal setting and
yeah and but you and then you just kind
of put it into the thing but now a lot
of the stuff I do is about really like
getting on the
vibrational level of having those things
so rather than looking at like oh I
really want a
house I like I do visualizations of
myself driving into the house
opening the door feeling like at home
and that's what I would do a lot when I
lived at that awful house but it helped
me like I guess it's similar to like
finding your happy place you know I
would like really just feel like I was
in my home whatever it was like and
feeling good and safe and you know and
then you just wake up one day and you're
like oh I'm in it yeah it's crazy and
they're like o I want more you know like
can I when I was a kid like I did a lot
a lot of like maladaptive daydreaming
cuz like I would just wanted to get out
of whatever situation I was in whether
like I was scared of my mom I was scared
of being beat I was force-fed whatever
it was I was like I I would do a lot of
I would Daydream these like and you know
things that I thought could never happen
but it got me out of my situation at
that time but most of those things that
I daydreamed about came true so crazy
right cuz it's like you really do
accidentally um Point your life in the
direction of that because you you did it
for so long in your head either as a
child or whatever so like now I look at
I'm like oh my God like everything that
I they dreamed of became true sometimes
I wonder too were you dreaming it or was
it pulling
you that's kind of make I don't know but
that's like a free will Destiny thing
and all the Divine timing ideas like
that's what gets me out of anxiety if
I'm like something's going wrong or like
if I show up to a show or for instance
last night I bombed on the show my like
clothes are bombed I was getting laughs
throughout the show but like my closer
bomb but when you're not getting the
laughs you're used to getting you're
like set and you're like I'm like oh
this isn't all of a sudden I'm like
watching myself it feels like going
through a trapo yeah I'm like where are
we what Bizarro world are we in this is
worked
yesterday um but I had to like explain
my closer I was like no no no no the
reason these words are together is this
but um I could get upset about that I
think it's fun it's kind of fun to bomb
no because it doesn't happen as often it
used to happen all the time you know
when I first started but um I could get
upset of that or it could be like oh
that's like exactly what needs to happen
for whatever the next thing is that
happens yeah you need that feeling I
think like whenever eye bomb any way
like it hurts like I'm not going to
obsess over it like I used to when I was
younger and that it would ruin my whole
night right but now like I do think that
feeling of like oh I failed is like is
important cuz then it will make me want
to never feel like that again even
though you know it will cuz that's just
part of the game but you it makes you
like go work harder again and yeah it's
like it's important I think to have
those feelings yeah sometimes not all
the time but I don't want to summon that
into my life yeah I know for sure I know
but it's like who cares it's a wait
juicy what's your type since we're going
to Austin together I need to know what I
looking out for okay so I've been
thinking about this a lot lately I even
single and I don't really know yet
because I think I'm similar to you in
the sense like I don't I don't always
just find people attractive it's like
rare for me to just see somebody and be
like who like there are certain guys
like um I did start looking at um the
Thunder Down Under
page which is really impressive if you
just end up with like a beefy Australian
yeah we're like on an Australian kick
today we really are I I got with a beefy
Australian a couple years ago a beef
Kake
a beef finder
yeah okay so Thunder Down Under men I
mean it's hard it's hard to look at them
and be like I don't know I don't find
them attractive because they're like
very attractive but like normal like
walking down the I don't know it's like
I I'm more like I have to I Bond like
with the personality and there's like an
energetic thing that I have to like that
I'm attracted to that like so I don't I
don't really know and I haven't dated in
so long and I've been so like work
focused even before this last
relationship so it's like I I never
really went out to date it's like pretty
much the only guys i' would be into are
the ones that were initially into me we
like hang out with people for a job too
so it seems so insane to like take off
our hang to go on a like a planned hang
yeah also like planned dates it feels
like a [__] job interview so awward
went on to and and you know right away
be like no no no it felt like I was like
podcasting with someone who did they
know who you were um no they didn't know
who I was but it felt like I the lights
were on so do you like breast milk yeah
know that's exactly it and I I felt I
was like why am I talking like this like
why do I give a [__] but um I I'm
exactly like you where I just some guy
recently told me like and he F he said
it with his whole chest he's like wow
you really don't have a type cuz he saw
just like three different exes that I've
had and he was like I didn't believe you
at first he's like but holy sh K you do
not have a type having a type is kind of
weird it is right well it's like are you
chasing someone that you loved back in
the day or had a crush on or like how do
you develop a type or like I I feel like
there have been times where like I date
guys that look a little too much like my
family where I'm like what are we doing
here your type as yourself yeah I'm like
twin
brother he's hot Cersei and Jamie
forever I have the best picture of me
and Todd I mean me and Max my twin
brother watching a sex scene between the
two brother and sister and we're but
we're like kind of squished close what
movie is this of Game of Thrones Oh I
thought it was like a porno you no yeah
we were just jerking off when we were
probably couldn't watch Game of Thrones
together cuz that's just a little weird
no we were squished it was funny I'm not
even really Max and I aren't usually
squished I remember every time Max like
leans his head on my shoulder I'm like
don't move it's like my dog when I was
little if if she put her head on you and
you move she would leave the room yeah
that's how Max is like you don't want
move is showing me affection and love oh
my goodness okay so no type so we're
both similar so we're g to be both
pretty lost in Austin yeah lost in
Austin lustin lost in Austin We're got
to sell that script after the rider
strike is done yeah cuz no one's working
on anything right now so we're basically
of no help to each other I wish we could
just go see them maale strip club okay
let's do that do they have any I don't
think they they probably don't have any
even in Vegas I n tax get that [__] out
of my town call that in a small
town they don't got boobs or
nothing wait what about we just go to a
regular strip club cuz I always find
like I feel like there always are pretty
interesting dudes there wait I have a
take what do you guys think about CU
back in the day I met a guy at um Home
Depot oh already so
hot wait what aisle oh he was outside
asking for work no I'm just
kidding no he worked he was selling
power tool he was selling he worked for
the power tool company and he was doing
like an exhibit selling power tools okay
so Cowboy Carl was really hot yeah he
had like been fat and so he was like hot
with stretch marks so you're like you've
been places oh the chocolate chip on the
shoulder is my favorite cuz they don't
realize how hot they are they still got
a little bit of hips left but that's
okay we just don't have to look that
direction when I met his mom his mom
came town when I met his mom she was
like he was like Mom she used to be a
go- go dancer I was like why are you
telling your mom that part I was also a
special head
teacher oh my God I was just like this
is so weird and she was like you were I
was like oh my God Julian tells me he a
famous male strip club in Austin hun
Mania H Mania sounds great oh my God I
bet Bobby would love to go that would be
so funny okay we get Rogan to go with
youan what there what if he like came
out moderating moderating the strip wait
a second Matt R's there you're like oh
my God wait do we need reservations or
we just go in we might because I want to
go so my best friend and I tried to see
Thunder Down Under and they like they
were like do you have tickets and we're
like no and I tried to slip them cash
you need tickets we're thirsty for it
yeah okay we're going to hun Mania I'm
going to buy tickets that sounds awesome
and I bet you it goes late so we could
go after the show yeah I'm Jo hunk hunk
Mania 50% Deposit they all also do you
kill Tony that week they're all on the
line they're like I have to tell you
about a a joke I wrote about having sex
with my stepdaughter wait so what
happened with the guy at Home
Depot he I just didn't we didn't Vibe oh
he was too
like I don't know what a great place to
meet someone so but it felt like the
right I was like oo it felt hot to meet
a man at Home Depot it's my my friends
when um they go to Hawaii their their
first stop is always this place called
food Food Land but it's the Poke section
cuz that's where all like at a certain
time that's where all like the thick
thick the what do you call it the you
came up with a term the thick buted
daddies are thick buted daddies they
just got done surfing oh love a thick no
we like they're just like construction
workers bottom yeah like Annie and I
were in Hawaii and we were just like I I
be like we were trailing this guy at the
airport like
thied carrying his like toolbox right oo
who checks a
toolbox who carries on their toolbox
it's so hot so funny but that's it like
all my friends are was like food Land um
Pokey section is where the thick but
daddies are poke is because it's like
kind of Keto no I think that's where
they're going and they probably have
families honestly and they're just
buying dinner an easy dinner there is
something about like a someone got you
young no yes thick daddy there's nothing
hotter than a guy who's like oh no I've
been married since I was 19 they nothing
to do oh they nothing to do with you
never my wife you're like
oh so quiet I'll just F to this
later you have good family values all
right hun Mania it is I'm jealous that
would be epic Julian tells me it's a DL
gay gay Place Home Depot Home Depot is
yeah Home Depot is hunk Mania no no Home
Depot oh Home Depot's like a very I
would say hunk hunk Mania would be kind
of like not DL not DL it's like but is H
Mania seems like um um gay for pay right
seems like it yeah oh but Home Depot is
like a DL like you can like there's
people are cruising around Home Depot
yeah it's like yeah wow what am I doing
there all [__] day
then Jesus I will say I went there the
other day and I was
like did it lose its magic you check
which one which um Home Depot I went to
the one in Marina del re you got to go
to the valley yeah they're hard workers
but Marina del re has like Marina del re
has like like a like a garden section
that you're walking and you're like the
last time I was there I was on mushrooms
but I was like this is why aren't we
hanging out here wait they all have
garden section I know but it's a better
garden section oh I bet it would be in
it's a beach it's like a beach garden
section you're like oh I can smell the
beach and yeah I like just walking my
dog through this yeah like over
especially over the lockdown there's
nothing to do but Home Depot and so we
just walked
well that's where a lot of people do
like their dog training sessions is at
Depot I see like doberman's there and
they're like what why is there a
doberman and a [__] like lumbered and
it's it's because they um there's a lot
of space in big aisles and say dog
trainers take dogs there all the time
that makes sense they're dog friendly
man Home Depot is the best except I got
in a fight with a lady once cuz I was
like do you have a box we were getting a
bunch of plants I was like do you have a
box and she went a
box I was
like I didn't think that was a crazy
what kind of box did you need like a TR
like something where you can carry the
things you bought out she was like oh
like a regular cardboard it was like
Asbergers like you have Asbergers I'm
why you mad at me like the weird I'm
like this is a box store like yeah you
have an aisle of them this is crazy like
I'll buy one Jesus she was so like
disgusted with my question I was like
about to get spit on at Home Depot damn
maybe you ever say something and people
go like oh you said the thing wrong but
in your head it sounds like you said it
right what if you said like can I see
lick your box can I lick your box
nword and she was like
what did you guys ever see the um the
morning TV interview where I actually
said like the term the nword yes it's so
funny I didn't see I said nudes and they
freaked out yeah they said oh you like
sced your hands and I go oh no one tells
me that since her nudes leaked and they
heard me say nudes and they got like so
scared and then I just didn't even mean
I just went like oh are you sad I said
the N word cuz I didn't want to say
nudes again yeah and then they were like
they were like short circuiting they're
like and I was like the N word didn't
your agent call you or something no
because then the club owner text my
agent this idiot text my agent and goes
Annie just said the nword on live TV oh
God okay with no quotes or anything and
then my he was in a meeting at CIA with
like all the agents and then I get a
call like I'm getting like frantic calls
and I'm like I pick I oh was hilarious
he goes we're going to get through this
we talked about it's like I I think we
can like I think it's okay like I think
we can still work with you and I'm like
I'm like no I said I go no it was funny
it was not I didn't say I'm like I
promise you're never GNA catch me saying
the actual I promise you I won't be that
client right I can promise
you but it was crazy God that's a really
funny story the whole Board of
CIA they were like all it was like their
meeting that they have it's so funny
they're doing just like PR crisis mode I
mean they were like we think we can keep
you like this guy almost got be dropped
by my agent so crazy I love that if you
had said it though they were still
thinking of keeping you they were like
they were going to you know maybe they
just say that in the beginning for the
first 24 hours like yeah yeah yeah so
you don't go around say so you don't
like freak out you don't go on a rampage
you know who I matched with on Ria
recently and I want to know you guys'
opinion whether or not I should my age
and I'll throw up all over this place no
but we have to bleep this out obviously
and like blur my mouth but um do you
guys know who um is yeah like yeah the
football player you pull him up I mean
you have with them but yeah do you think
that he will tear my vagina in half it's
all I that's all I really want to know I
think he'll I I can I think that he
probably is going to ask you how your
weekend was we oh yeah no he didn't open
with that what did he open with can I
tell you yeah can I read it yeah it's
actually really sweet okay I'll read it
out loud okay he said he's like I would
like to put a touchdown in your goal
post I was like oh if he had said that I
would have been like okay he's like I
want to suck your fee football um he
said oh he just said good morning Kila
oh that's pretty good yeah and I why
don't you just say our names it's so
easy that's true I could be a I could
just be a guy and just woo every girl
say our names and lean in and true gum
us I know it's so true I like hearing my
own name and then he basically said
how's it going pretty basic and then I
said you know B anyways but he Bas I
said hey like I just got out of a
relationship even though it's been like
two years so I was like I'm not really
like I haven't met anyone I don't intend
to go on dates with anyone RI this is
more like an e boost thing I was pretty
honest and he he's like o my type um
yeah then basically he was like oh I
totally understand if you're not trying
to date anyone right now um but thanks
for even swiping I was hoping you'd be
interested in me but um but swiping
because because you find me attractive
isn't total Cho liver right and so I was
like maybe not fully chopped and then
but I was like oh he's really like
sweet do you think he's going to rip
through my vagina though yes please I'm
Kling you think we can keegle it back
together he looks like he works for a
Thunder Down Under I'm
literally soing wet right
now I'm like what are we talking about
and his the way he talked to you was
perfect I know it's so polite and then
he dm'd me on Instagram he was like oh
here you are cuz he probably didn't
think I was going to reply on Rya again
or come back there and so he found me on
Instagram instead I feel like he'd be so
fun but recently in the last two weeks I
feel like people like famous athletes
how loyal could they be yeah of course
that's a good point but it could be
really
fun you know or not yeah but I don't
know if you're looking if you're looking
to get into a serious relationship that
would be my Fe you need to be serious
with him I think you could yeah
he's bleep that out too because I'm just
just curious yeah I have many boyfriends
who would be so jealous of you how tall
is he
that's gonna be it Annie is our Football
Talk Annie and football Corner guys
football Corner guys when you want to
hear about sports you come to trash
Tuesday okay Esther's not into sports
Kila and I we can't shut up about it we
love balls he's 64 KLA he's 6'4 oh
that's not that's actually not I thought
he was like 67 or something that's not
too bad it's perfect all right all right
do we um
are you are you guys saying Yes to the
Dress yes okay good yes to the draft I'm
saying I'm saying shaft to the
[Laughter]
draft does he have like CTE yeah what
what was his position um he was a wide
receiver I think are those getting hit
in the headers they get hit in the head
not as much but still yeah they can the
quarterbacks are the ones that don't get
[__] up right not not as much I want
you to hook up with Tom Brady he yeah no
I he just isn't my type he he kisses his
son too
much they broke up they broke up where
you been didn't do it oh my God you're
not into sports like we are yeah lot
about sports I met a bunch of football
players on the road they were Santino's
friends and they're so nice Santino
keeps so many secrets of the people he's
friends with he has so many friends he's
friend everyone that you'd be like can I
have your photograph Santino is friends
I know because he's like a he's a mayor
even his Cadence and everything is so
like like gubernatorial he's just he
could run for office really he could I'd
vote for him but V all these people like
they they love him so much too like how
do you know all these people he's so
Charming yeah but all these NFL players
came out to one of our shows and they
were all just so nice they were like
just gentlemen and very friendly and
they just love to laugh and like they're
really cute
let's get this guy off the screen it's
super
distracting that's so cute he's not
giving up on you you kind of rejected
him he's probably obsessed with you now
I
know is that how to do it if you say
like I don't want to date then they'll
they're like no let's get married yeah
yeah like if you did okay here we go
okay so there's this article that asks a
bot on the side is it adultery if you
cheat with an AI
companion what's an AI companion seen
the movie her yeah so something similar
to that just not as advanced yet but you
can have sex with it yeah let's say yeah
I mean what's the point if we're just
holding hands well Walken didn't have no
sex oh emotionally yeah he was there I
bet he jacked off I'm sure he all over
her robot face he had to get a new
phone wait so is it cheap eating I mean
I mean we're right around the corner
from possibly having this like be a real
option for the lonely GS like myself
right yeah but I mean I hope it's I hope
this is for cheating and not people just
living their entire lives with the robot
but is it cheating though let's suppose
okay Todd okay just may five years from
now um the real doll just becomes even
realer and now she's able to have
emotions she's able to respond she's
able to listen and then you come home
one day I can't compete without a
listener
that I cannot give him so you would
probably just you know understand so
let's let's I've never let my boyfriends
like [__] other girls I feel like a lot
of girls that I know and and boyfriends
that I've had have been in open
relationships where they were like maybe
more sexually demanding than the girl
wanted so they would be like oh you can
just like [__] other girls and then
dated that guy and he tried to pull that
with me and I was like I don't like that
so I don't I think if I'm not giving you
what you need then we shouldn't be in a
relationship and I know that
relationships like EB and flow but I
think with open communication it's like
but it's it's a robot I feel like cuz
Todd's obviously with you cuz he likes
your Dynamic so I feel like if he had a
robot it'd be exactly like you and like
Todd where are you Todd give me water
between people being like I need water I
mean okay would you be okay with that
then just like as a proxy a proxy for
when you're gone or let's say you have
to be on set for a movie like for two
months and there's just a robot an at
home the babysit on
no I no what if Randy needed it cuz he
missed you
no Randy doesn't get a fake mother what
do you think juicy live in my absence
and miss me it would be weird for
me yeah if I was like in a relationship
and I was like okay bye and then he's
like dusting the robot off okay what
about this what about if it's like like
douching her you're like e
a brothel where's the vinegar oh my God
Todd what do you call those ones those
things you buy at best byy to clean your
computer like the the air duster yeah is
that what you buy them for we did
different things with those in
Philly
sexual wait so let's suppose you know
let's suppose it's a brothel but it's
all real dolls or AI Companions and he's
just like look I had a with the boys and
we went to you know the sexo tech they o
cookie the the doll yeah and we but it
was just with a doll like is that a
fight or is that like oh I get that or
that's what is that I just am not really
in relationships with guys that are like
strip club guys or like yeah Todd is
definitely like I just don't like
yeah yeah I don't know I just never have
dated a guy that's like that I mean I
have but it doesn't last
long I don't want to feel bad threatened
all I want to feel comfortable and happy
yeah the robot broel is really funny to
me though what if it was an online
version so it's someone building out an
AI companion to have some sort of
relationship with online isine and not a
physical doll I feel like that's similar
to a therapist yeah go to a therapist
but you're but it you're saying it's
more of like a romantic connection yeah
that's even worse for me because if
you're going to somebody else with your
feelings that to me is the ultimate
betrayal right instead of teaching your
compan your real life companion what you
need and want you need you're teaching
the AI version this is for incels this
is to stop the school shooting yeah and
I think it's a necessary thing yeah this
is great I'm not against this it's just
like I would be like Todd are you
kidding also I feel like Todd would tell
me if he was like I think I'm having
feelings for this doll yeah yeah Todd
would would be pretty up for about that
I just can't
even I don't know so for me if I were to
I like this like messy bunch she does
look like a [__] like she'd be like
your penis is small I'm going to step on
it like for me being single right now I
would definitely dabble in some AI
companionship but more for the novelty
of being one of the first girls to
actually do it but also Imagine like you
date a guy and his last girlfriend was
Ai and he's like she let me tell you
is he let me guess he late he can never
[Laughter]
commit perfected AI but they still talk
like this Dam he has
[Laughter]
herpes I'm pregnant I love this the
younger generation is just so open about
their herpes and it's like I'm so proud
of jenz they are not afraid of the
things that ail them like I see a lot of
young people who are still being like
yeah I have heard piece I just want to
let you know up front and I hear these
things and I'm like oh my God we were so
terrified we gave them we were the ones
that gave it to them speak for yourself
no I don't have herpes yet wait is um is
Todd Jen or is he Millennial young Mill
Millennial no clue I don't know I don't
know he's younger than me 29 he was born
in 94 jenz shares
everything yeah yes like I guess it's
good but some of the thoughts they can
keep in their head
they just like they just inject just a
little bit of Shame back just a little
bit well they'll get it later I think
they just haven't developed self
awareness um my cutie how how are you on
time
Stella Sean Bobby come give us some
views are we good on time 108 I can't
see him 108 yeah saw that body I go
that's got to be a Bobby body I never
seen a body like that oh bab anymore
sorry meat nasty you want me to go get
nesa my ex-girlfriend nestia would let
me [__] her in the plastic
butthole is it like replenishing wetness
too they like make it moist I like well
if the if the um sorry I just breezed
right over
that wait what were we talking about if
she like REM moistens herself nestia her
name is nesa her name is nesa oh I was
like wait I REM
moisten I was like I do that
too like NASA used to spit on my [__]
you're like oh my God how yeah I can't
compete with a thing that just abides
like I'm a [__] [__] sometimes I
would like I hope they think like they
like warm bodies and of a human make
them clean the house and cook dinner
like I would get like a robot wife if I
break up with Todd he's allowed to get
an an Annie AI if we get divorced yeah
why are they making them only for sex we
should have robot Maids yeah I guess
that's kind of like Roberta Roberta
welcome to my house Roberta I would keep
make it a white name I think it's
appropriate well robot what's a white
robot name uh well Roberta could be
white I probably wouldn't name I know
white Roberta Jennifer I'd probably just
call it robot wait do people robot
that's so demeaning but it I don't want
it to have feelings do people still name
their children Linda
Jennifer um like these type of kind of
Ruth well Ruth I know is a popular name
again it is but Linda uh maybe what else
Baby Ruth you name your kid after a
[__] I know your your daughter is
here who's my daughter your son your son
she exed M he can't he has bad eyesight
I can't see him either but I hear it was
Shuffle are you guys shooting something
yeah come in we're ending what are you
doing here you guys still right here hey
juice what are you doing here they asked
me to come you're betraying come sit
what I thought we were all one family
you Bobby what do you think about having
an AI girlfriend named Nastia and would
you get an AI girlfriend here pass the
mic to him do they have a vagina yeah
like do they have a vagina yeah no they
don't have one no vagina why I like it
they have a vagina but it's in the
butthole does it work as well the same
way it rewet itself is there poo flavor
yeah put a spray on put any flavor you
want it's like a flavor packet like a
vape how are you you good affection in
the head that so funny the other day I
like any the other day I dissed her how
I knew you were to this was fun so um we
were at The Comedy Store and um I knew
Adam Sandler was upstairs cuz I told him
he told she told me and I was going to
go up to say hi and she goes um can I
come with you I go
no and then her face got all weird no it
didn't yeah it did you got all weird
baby what's up I was five plays ahead of
you yeah I said oh here's Bobby I'm
going to tell him about Adam Sandler
he's going to go up I'm going to ask him
to come he's going to say you think was
going to happen up there what was the
end he's going to say no and then
everybody's GNA lie wait did you talk to
Adam Sandler mhm you did yeah what did
he say you weren't up there very long he
goes hey Bob I go hey and he goes what's
going on I go did you call him ad if you
called you Bob no I go Captain Sandler
oh I call him Captain Sandler and then
then we I just sat there for a second
while he was writing and I kind of went
okay I go I guess I
go you got the Vibes that I got the vi
yeah whoa so no AI girlfriend I mean is
it a real thing with a warm [__] warm
everything no this version just knows
how to like exactly what to say is
taught what to say to you he doesn't
care about people he doesn't want to
hear anyone say anything yeah I like it
when they're like so you like the dolls
can I put autism in
there I love Au yeah you could do that
you think so you could program anything
I think some autism in there yeah what
else you have to clean it though what
he's not going to clean that's what I
was thinking
but you've got to keep it clean is it a
physical thing though yeah it could be I
put a real doll and the go ahead there's
a couple versions so one is just like an
emotional I don't want emotions he
doesn't want emot okay so you want to
sex and spit on you and stuff oh that's
sexy yeah can you put a little how can
you put like Doug Stan Hope's like
personality in there she like smoke
cigarettes like the perfect
woman anyway I'll see you bye bye Bobby
I love the white on white okay a on what
his I mean where's Esther she is um not
it's just a one time thing that what is
this is this where you're doing it now
yes yes you've been doing it here yes
this is the second one yes yeah okay I
like it it's cute right isn't it great
yeah it's
awesome slugs thank you so much for
being here we want to thank our special
guest Bobby Lee um I'm just kidding
thank our beautiful Jessie me out of the
whole thing yes we're like we just put
Bobby's face over yours oh my God didn't
I do that on something oh I did it with
Josh it's his face but my voice saying
we should go to Thunder Down Under
Thunder Down Under baby H Mania check
these girls out at hunkamania two
weekends ago and and we want you to push
the Subscribe like comment and push that
little bell so you get all the
notifications and we're just having a
blast we're had so much fun we'll see
you guys next week bye thank you Jessie
thanks for
[Music]
having